la chose intéressante à propos de Tomorrowland
est que c'est une idée intrigante et qu'elle est
liée à Disney et d'une manière vraiment
intéressante dans notre monde moderne
partout où nous regardons, nous voyons l'influence de la
science sur notre vie quotidienne, beaucoup
de choses qui semblent impossibles maintenant
deviendront des réalités  demain Walt Disney
était vraiment intéressé par l'avenir et
toutes les possibilités qu'il pourrait apporter
complètement jusqu'à ce que nous enflammions son
imagination créative beau demain
juste un rêve loin qui dit que nous allons dans des
endroits où il y a des progrès à venir beaucoup de
ces cercles autour de qui Walt Disney
était-il vraiment tourné vers l'avenir avec l'
idée qu'il y avait de l'espoir et
des résultats positifs, il a proposé des
systèmes qui permettraient aux gens de
mieux travailler ensemble en optimisant la
race humaine Walt Disney jouait toujours avec
quelque chose que vous savez, que ce soit de l'
animatronique ou du transport de masse
l'urbanisme du monorail est son idée
de ce que le monde pourrait être comme
un prototype expérimental co  communauté de
demain, je pense qu'il pensait que la meilleure façon
de le faire n'était pas de prêcher à ce sujet,
mais de le faire, il y a beaucoup de
similitudes entre le dernier projet
sur lequel il travaillait sur le centre d'epcot et la
terre de demain qui était sa
version utopique de ce que nous  avait notre meilleur pourrait être
depuis que je suis un petit enfant Tomorrowland
ne m'a pas toujours semblé traditionnellement de la
science-fiction c'est presque
comme un fait scientifique certaines de ces choses
ne se sont pas encore produites mais elles peuvent arriver
[ __ ] seule
que la grande chose à propos de Walt a
inspiré  nous pour faire cette étincelle d'
optimisme, nous obtenons une grande toile sur laquelle
peindre parce que le mot même
Tomorrowland est évocateur, il évoque le jeu
et il évoque la promesse de fraîcheur vous savez
quelque chose qui est inconnu qui est sur le point d'
être ici endroit où les gens vivent réellement
une vie et  trouver n'importe où ailleurs dans le
monde